now where is
my um
pretty amazing this one child
that's pretty amazing
oh that's was taken over in france
and these are two of my buddies
and that's me
watch it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
memories are still there i i live it i
see it
i was not just a veteran i was in the
invasion of normandy in the invasion of
normandy no one knows what more is
unless you have been there in it
[Music]
i was up late one night on my computer
and i saw this wonderful story about
charles atterly true american hero the
people in this community really want to
help those in need especially those who
have given so much time serving their
country and serving their community like
charles has he was in need of a new ac
system there was some mold issues and so
we all just wanted to do everything we
could to help charles
all right mr adelie
so this was done
this morning by the team
we got the drywall all patched up
so once the flooring is done we can
start bringing in the cabinets and the
actual kitchen materials
sounds good to me all right
mr adelie
when i looked at him i just started
thinking about
the possibilities of what it was like
and
what he went through
and once he started talking i snapped
back
and listened
you still love living here seem to
try to move me
you'll have a fight on your hat
yeah
these guys came out here donated their
time their professionals all of our
volunteers and all of our partners
everyone has just fallen in love with
charles and they want to do whatever
they can for him
people need help you know it could be
you one day you got businesses willing
to give up material you got the firemen
we come off duty we want to come and put
the work in
one of the issues i see these days
especially with people my age is you
don't interact with people who are your
elders and i mean there's so much that
can be learned from them i've spoke with
charles several times about the history
of miami he is 93 years old he provides
that glimpse into the past and it's just
invaluable
2nd of may 1944
campaign normandy
what
is the definition of hero
what is it
you can see all the pictures in the
movie well that's it you're going about
your business you forget
i've seen it all
you can look to me this time charles
ready for him to enlist in the service
and fight for a country that really
didn't
at that time you know favor
people like he and i
that says to me something about
an individual he inspires so many people
from different walks to want to help him
because you know what quite frankly we
are
that's how i see it we owe him
somebody like that we have to always
show our gratitude and appreciation we
can never let that go and it's not just
one day in november
you've got to
live in a here and now
the only reason why we're in this world
is what we're doing right now to be
there for each other that's what i
learned from him
i'm concerned about
the moment and i know better than to
think about tomorrow oh my god i can't
even handle today
each and every one of you has become a
part of my life
each and every one of you is a part of
me now
that's how i
feel all i can say is thank each and
every one of you
[Music]
you